good morning John it's Wednesday
September 5th
you
hello evil lady and the grocery store it
seems that you don't know what the
express lane is for it says 12 items are
less mature except from that I guess and
you started the argument about coupons
oh don't make me kill you over 25 cents
I'll give you a freaking quarter if it
makes that much difference in you just
remember to forget to get your husband
to be right back with it okay that's it
I'm gonna kill you
yeah I'm gonna kill you possibly your
whole family - all I want is some
courtesy kindness maybe an apology if
you don't get out of my grocery line I
lose for me its totality you forgot your
spine I'm usually a very peaceful person
but I'm gonna kill you
I just wrote a note to the guy down the
street recently invested in a giant SUV
it said I'll you know that we're
fighting no more so you can get your
badass home from the grocery store you
better trade it in there I'm gonna kill
you yeah I'm gonna kill you with a car
bomb and your age too
I don't think he too much to ask for you
to be bit less of an ass
I suggest you reinvest in a Honda Fit if
you don't you're gonna regret and I'm
usually a very peaceful person but I've
gotta kill you it's 3:00 a.m. and my
neighbor upstairs is actually worse and
my worst night there's the had some
friends over for some late-night Red
Rover
and now yeah they're practicing tap
dance
you
yeah I'm gonna kill you and all your
loud ass friends - I don't think it'd be
too much to ask for you to be a bit less
of an ass if I don't get some peace in
want of a - honestly my god I'm usually
a very peaceful but I'm gonna kill you
I'm really not an angry person
but people just get on a nerve sometimes
thanks to Catherine for all the help
with that song particularly with coming
up with the idea for it and several of
the lines so if you want more than that
I'm afraid I can't give it to you
because singing like that has made my
voice a little bit weak I am NOT a bass
I have to work for it and it airs it up
in there my neck vein coming up bergna
fern anyway I got to go see you tomorrow